some of you guys, maybe it's not the people that are listening right now,
but some of you guys are so in this mindset of like, I have these 20 sites and I got a couple
that are getting leads and I got to close one, two, three, four, five before I can go presale.
No, no, no, no. If you have a site that's getting leads and it fits the due diligence,
passes the sniff test, go sell it. And if you can't sell it, because whatever reason,
you tried a couple of times and you're just kind of stuck, set it down. That doesn't mean
you need to go onto your next one. Cause I know some of you guys are like, well, I need to get my
hosting taken care of and all this stuff. Forget about that. Go, if you're struggling selling your
existing sites because you did crappy due diligence or whatever, pause those, do SEO,
come over here, follow my recommendations, concrete, tree service, foam and sprays from insulation,
go and sell a presale, get your momentum. Now you got momentum and you can go get another one or
you can come back. And I promise you guys, it's crazy when you go to sell the same person that
you had a problem with last time, but now you got momentum, how much easier it is to close.